let's talk about one of the first
symptoms that can occur if you're low in
salt in your body
which this is actually very very common
it's weakness okay overall feeling of
weakness
you're kind of tired let's talk about
why
first of all the the root word salad is
a latin word for salted greens okay
because the romans used to dip their
lettuce in salt which is interesting
the word salary or sale sal
is the latin word for salt and the
romans sometimes used to get paid in
salt
instead of money which is another
interesting point
you should never consume refined salt
always is sea salt that's unpolluted
himalayan salt is great there's many
other salts that are just as good
because the refined salt is just sodium
chloride and you're not getting all the
other
minerals in the right balance that you
need plus to add aluminum
which is not good salt is also needed to
make hydrochloric acid in your body
to help digest protein to help absorb
minerals
to help kill pathogens and
many people are low in hcl and then they
start getting acid reflux indigestion
bloating especially as you get older an
average person as a very minimum needs
one teaspoon of sea salt every single
day
but in many cases they need more
especially if they exercise
or do the ketogenic diet now
i think the worst scenario a person can
be in is if they're
on a low salt diet and they're drinking
lots of water so they're diluting
that little bit of salt that they have
and then they get on a diuretic
which will then cause the water to come
out but also the sodium too
making them very deficient in sodium and
if they're on a high carb diet
with all those other factors what's
going to happen is they're going to
retain the fluid in the sodium but in
the wrong places so
they're going to be in a real bad
situation so you're generally just going
to have this feeling of weakness and
tiredness
and then when you consume some salt
you're going to feel a lot better right
away
so if you're endowed or confused about
this just add a little more salt to the
diet and see if your energy doesn't just
perk up
when i take my electrolyte powder which
has a lot of
sodium i always add more salt to it
especially if you're going on keto
and you're no longer consuming all these
refined carbs
with all this extra sodium but if
someone's just starting keto and they're
they've been on a high sodium refined
diet
then they don't need to do that because
they already have too much sodium
from things like the monosodium
glutamate and the extra
sodium that they put in a lot of junk
foods but here's
why you get energy from sodium okay
number one
sodium excites the heart muscle so
without enough sodium
the heart can't pump and so you don't
get enough oxygen
to the cells you don't get enough
nutrition
you're going to feel tired and weak and
just as a side note when i talk about
sodium
i'm really recommending sea salt because
you wouldn't necessarily want to take
sodium
as an individual mineral because sodium
works with so many other things so
you want to get your sodium from sea
salt
now sodium also regulates calcium
calcium homeostasis so without sodium
calcium can't really work in the body
so then you don't get the contraction of
the muscles you don't get the rhythm of
the heart
and you can't produce the energy that
you need
okay so that relationship is very very
important
also sodium is involved in this really
key
pump in the cells that produce voltage
because the cell is like a battery so
you need sodium for that pump
you also need potassium as well and so
if you're low in sodium you're going to
have low
voltage okay in the body and here's
another interesting thing about sodium
sodium is very important it's vital
in making energy in the mitochondria
in your kidneys you have the most
concentrated
mitochondria okay simply because sodium
is so
important that the kidney has to
maintain a very high level of energy
to recycle sodium and so this is just
another reason why the body considers
sodium
as something that is very very important
and last point sea water the chemistry
of seawater
is virtually identical to the watery
portion
of your blood so when you consume more
sea salt
you're fortifying your blood
hey before you go real quick i have a
course
entitled how to bulletproof your immune
system
it's a free course i want you to take it
and here's why
here's you here is your
environment everyone
is focused on this over here avoiding
your environment but what about here
what about strengthening
your immune system that's what's missing
this course will show you
how to bulletproof yourself and so you
can tolerate and resist your environment
much better
by strengthening your own immune system
i put a link down in the description
right down below
check it out and get signed up today